you may want to tell the audience your
hot sauce story because I know you're
not a fan of hot sauce
so uh you know first off they duck your
head into some selts of water until you
just and when you inhale it just
explodes your head and then they beat
you and
and after some days and you [ __ ] took
other people out of the and you could
hear them beating and crying and beating
them and I was black and blue but it was
no more than in a in a good fight she
would have it wouldn't bother me that
bad
but they took me out naked and chained
me up and buttered my bum
and then they filled it full of Hot
Chili Peppers holy moly and I did talk
ugly
I thought if I only ever find you did
that ever like every time you go to a
restaurant and they say would you like
some hot sauce did I completely mess
with you for the rest of your life for
no I'm good on the hot sauce yeah you
leave it alone
but no spicy food there's a little more
to it then they hung a dead man in the
cell with me and it was just a little
sale of July and it was really hot
and the man was frozen and he was
wrapped in strips of newspaper like a
mummy and uh after a while the
formaldehyde started to melt and looked
like he was crying hanging on the meat
hook and he's opened up so I could see
his liver
and then the fluid start running out of
him went on the went on the floor and up
the place was not even six foot square
and I put my face under the door so I
could breathe
and as I breathed the fresh air I went
to sleep and then I'm also breathing
that fluid that was in him and I had
pink flying pigs so I know where Walt
Disney got his ideas from
and when I came to I didn't know which
was real and which was a dream
so this this is the first time you were
arrested and all these stories are
happening in Mexico yes correct oh yeah
so you haven't gotten involved in
Colombia at this many years I didn't get
okay so you're in jail the hot sauce
Story the dead man and the cell are you
this like right now you're just like
this happy-go-lucky like zero percent do
I feel drug smug Smuggler criminal Vibe
out of you whatsoever it's very apparent
how likable you are are do you have the
same demeanor at that time of your life
or oh no I memorized his face and I was
hoping to look him up one day so you're
being serious oh probably not but I mean
you just do you think of that that's why
I'm doing that I'm saying about his
personality now you've interviewed
countless amounts of
let's just call them illegal
entrepreneurs yeah his personality is
not very common for that type of that's
a strength though that's that's a very
big string because you're you know when
when you're the guy that it comes across
as being harmless he couldn't harm
anybody that's the most powerful guy in
the room really oh my God
I'm listening to them all I'm thinking
about his usual suspect yeah and all the
stories I'm like where's he picking up
I'm looking behind me thinking some of
this stuff is coming but obviously
you're a great Storyteller and you know
that you're a wonderful Storyteller but
so at this point has the jail time have
these experiences 99 of people if they
had that hot sauce experience the the
the the that you had not hot salad I
keep saying hot sauce the experience
that you had
they're probably like you know what babe
I think I'm done yeah I'm gonna go back
to Redondo okay let's go back to you
know and just kind of hang out why keep
coming back to it especially that close
call
I don't know it didn't it didn't you
know when it was out the
um the people that where I was shot down
for the load they I had paid them 17 000
so they gave them money after a month or
so I got the word out and uh my wife
came down and was trying oh oh boy I
mean she can tell the story about going
between those sales and visiting me and
the visit the day that's we have the
little Shacks you can shack up with you
with your woman in the courtyard oh my
gosh so and she's just walking straight
with her basket for food and them
reaching each side with their hands out
uh
but anyway somebody come and paid the
seventeen thousand dollars and I was
taking out the back door of the jail
and put into a brand new pickup with a
horse's head only then taken to the bank
and the banker told me because he spoke
English that this Joaquin has paid them
seventeen thousand dollars Roberto
Robert has paid somebody in the jail to
get you out now that that's paid for
and so when I caught that airplane it
was the Fourth of July 1974 and when
them Wheels came up I thought
free really did get out of there at that
time how much money you have in the bank
how much cash you got in the bank this
is 74. maybe half a million dollars half
a million dollars 74 half a million
dollars like four million dollars today
three million dollars it's real money
yeah I've got to retired but but did you
but this this story was prompted based
on when I asked you a question about the
firefighters the co-workers I don't know
where what prompted you telling that
story because what I was trying to find
out is you're still a firefighter in
Redondo Beach that the firefighters
start realizing why is this guy pulling
up in a Cadillac what's he doing that
they start asking questions that they
start reporting was there an
investigation or no they played it cool
I know that there was one one fireman
there that went to the police or went to
the DEA or read that transcripts so so
one guy went one guy went did that do
anything did that no need to do anything
or no I thought and and I really thought
for all those years that they had to
catch you and they never did catch me
how long in U.S until they caught you
from 1973. oh they never did catch me I
was uh for 12 years I was until 1982.
um before they arrested me and they
charged me with continuing criminal
Enterprise I was number 41 that was ever
charged with that horrible
charge is the title 21 841 called
continuing criminal Enterprise and you
have to manage three organizations with
five people in each organization and it
carries up to life in prison
and wow John Gotti was number 42.
you were 41 he was 42 yes and he died in
there I gave up the money and uh they
dropped that charge and it gave me um I
think
choose any two marijuana charges and and
uh income tax and I got a total of 35
years with only five years sentenced in
20 and 30 years of Probation Parole
so I got out after a couple of two and a
half years so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]